[Music]
and we do it to ourselves news this is
submitted by danger boys from Boston a
new study finds that human self generate
their own misinformation even when given
accurate info whom is mr. gentlemen
information humans do what's this story
about so this study I was conducted with
two doctoral students and it was
published in the Journal of human
communication research and they found
that when people are given accurate
statistics on controversial topics they
tend to misremember those numbers in
order to fit their own their own bias
yeah yeah yeah they're saying like for
example in the study when people were
shown that the number of Mexican
immigrants in the United States declined
recently they tended to recall the
opposite so for example most people
believe that the number of Mexican
immigrants in the US grew between 2007
and 2014 but in fact that number went
from 12 point 8 million in 2007 to 11
point seven million in 2014 but even
though they were given these actual like
factual statistics they still would
remember the opposite that more in
Mexican immigrants came into the country
how would they know are they chilling at
the border going yep
look at all these Mexicans it's been
order to like continuously like feed
into their buyers and who are they
serving like people from [ __ ]
Minnesota or you know it depends on the
sample group because it's serving the
people who believe in the current
presidencies agenda so anybody believes
that people are coming to take jobs from
hardworking Americans it serves this are
the poor whites yeah which is crazy
because they wouldn't want to do the job
that most of them I would say welcome
I'm for the same one for the Midwest and
before I moved out here and I know
nobody work harder than black people
my people have to work twice as hard and
twice as long he now moved out to LA I
was like don't nobody work hard as
Mexicans I saw Mexicans selling an
umbrella in the rain and he wasn't using
one of the Umbra you you ain't got no
excuse he's getting soaked right now
he's like now I'm selling everything
Pham I'm not using none of this product
my brother would have been out there
with we would have bags on our shoes
with a trans bag on a poncho there were
three ed novellas we would have only had
two I bet his man was getting soaked
well Mexicans are waterproof - well you
should swap seats with me because she is
honest I've been sick for like the past
two weeks and my girl nothing absolutely
nothing that's so crazy
[Laughter]
yeah so you you were eventually like
where they were pulling these people
from I they don't mention that but I do
know that immigration papers is probably
like files like oh these students are
from the Ohio State University so maybe
from people in Ohio I don't know
but so the sample size is the Ohio
universe that's my guess they don't tell
me that for a fact I'm just letting you
know which University but they all
thought that like recently a lot of
Mexican immigrants were coming in
whoever I was that they picked in the
study but that's just an example the
right I think the main point is that
people whatever they already believe
that's in the face of numbers regardless
of is Mexican or how many armadillos
yeah it's called a confirmation bias
right so when you have something in the
forefront of your mind you're always
looking for it yeah like if you're
always thinking about Jesus then you see
them in toast you see them in wood you
see them you know yeah so they're saying
that so one of the students said this we
need to realize that internal sources of
misinformation can possibly be as
significant as or more significant than
external sources we live with our biases
all day but we only come into contact
with false information occasionally I
don't even know why people trust their
own five
that's the stupidest thing on earth it's
hard that [ __ ] smart like seriously
you got a people have to realize how
[ __ ] stupid they are themselves
I think everyone thinks they're smart
though that's the stupid part because
most people are [ __ ] dumb no but it's
not just that but you know how like in
with Facebook and Twitter like a lot of
these social media platforms end up
getting a lot of hate and like they get
into trouble because they are spreading
misinformation so I guess the study is
kind of saying like well we also play
into confirmation bias as well because
because exactly they're showing that
same thing that you're already
interacting with so you're not getting
any kind of diverse palette of politics
or anything like that you're just doing
the same yeah for sure
and then this study is just kind of like
confirming how yeah this these external
factors can play a part into the
misinformation that you are exposed to
but you're also doing it to yourself and
that's something we have to be very
mindful of always fact-checking story on
CNN or even Fox before I go like
strictly off of like Facebook or
Instagram something like that because
they'll just do some [ __ ] for clickbait
but like for the most part CNN or one of
the local networks they won't give you
the full story so I always do that now
I'm not gonna do much more than that I'm
not gonna fetch act like oh what city
I'm not gonna do all of that I just want
to make sure I got the good argument
points there was a law there was a law
prior to the 90s I think where news
outlets had to have at least 30% of the
opposition's perspective oh oh it was a
more balanced back then but then they
they lifted it and so now they could be
polarizing they could only report the
[ __ ] that they want to so Fox is only
reporting the right-wing stuff and then
all the other media outlets are only
reporting the left-wing stuff and that's
more profitable because people just want
that correction everyone wants to be a
part of the right team you don't want to
be a part of the wrong team so that's
kind of like the world we're living in
you know it's hard to break by as to
like it's similar to like a shopping
like you have to go into a store three
or four times before you buy that
product whatever that might be
yeah same with like opinion since I -
you have to like break someone slowly
you can just like him oh here's a good
stat that you need to look at - they're
not gonna do
when they've had years of perpetuated
misinformation they're not interested
believe you yep there has to be a slow
burn unfortunately class out humans are
yo and that's why I'm like it well
they're all [ __ ] dumb why why do you
believe yourself so much that's the
craziest thing that's the craziest thing
like you're not a [ __ ] that's good
perception that you have that you
understand that we don't know [ __ ] yeah
I got into so much trouble from trusting
myself and or thinking that I know
everything that's why human testimony is
not accurate at all no like they've done
so many like experiments or like witness
yeah eyewitness testimony yeah I say
humans like dinosaurs I witness
testimony like we don't remember [ __ ]
correct because 50% of what you remember
is a complete [ __ ] life yeah so
you'll be talking about yeah that's a
50-50 chance that you might be telling
the truth or not and you're tricking
yourself so you might be like remember
when this happened and that you're
filling in the blanks for a certain [ __ ]
and you're just having a blast in your
head but that's not what really went
down 50% is enough to make you like
questions or [ __ ] I mean 50 53 percent
of all marriages feel no pressure guys
but just know that that's it is real
good 30 pairs I'm talking about the pass
all the time that's why second and third
marriages by the way oh really
also that 50% is coming from the second
and third marriage and that thing you've
got stats oh also go into like the
nuance of what that study is about so
you hear that kind of something you're
like I'm your own right yes no felt dumb
but it's usually those people who
already bailed who are failing and
putting that stats statistics for a
first time right exactly like how many
people are first time getting it more
good book is freakonomics they have I
think they have a documentary now too
but for economics they kind of like tell
you like yeah there's all these graphs
and stats and all that and there's these
you know things that correlate but then
at the end of the day people kind of
fill in their own blake's and think that
this is the reason why and then they do
more research and they realize it's not
the reasons and that they thought not
when you fill in the bleak
is that the same you filling in the
blanks is that the same thing okay
sometimes you know like my bleakness can
take over and I didn't know if that was
like something that I need to do it like
the core memory is a tricky ass thing
though so words perception is those
Asian is the biggest thing because what
people don't also realize is I always
say like we share the same physical
plane right everyone's living in
different world yes we could all be
having of this this sit down but
everyone's having a different experience
right so but what happens is your
reality you think it's objective meaning
you think that's the real thing that's
happening so people we can all be facing
trafficking is I this is the best
analogy that I use it's like we can all
be in traffic right but having different
experiences one person is like I [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ] the other person could be
in the car with the girl and they're
like I wish this this is [ __ ] forever
because I want to be in here and talk to
whoever so all of these things can
change depending on your situation at
the time and what you're how you're
thinking about your situation so I'm
like Dan that's pretty crazy how do I
control that because if you could
control that you control your reality
and that's the hardest thing to do hey
you happiness yeah yeah people don't
know they can control their happiness
yeah I think there are victims to the
world yeah it's important because like a
lot of times if you have like fell off
my phone so I [ __ ] I lost my phone
business contacts all of that [ __ ] right
I get a new one I go on by newer right
but perspective it is like damn it's a
fortune I lost my phone but I'm thankful
I got enough money to go out and go to
know what being grateful I think changes
everything immediately yeah because you
could just cry about your lost phone or
you can ask for a fine my iPhone app and
just try to find your phone - yeah
there's what you microwaves you could
see it yeah always if people say
happiness is a choice in like I feel
like I feel like they're definitely
rings true in a lot of situations and
maybe not every situation know sometimes
it's hard to like meet you down
sometimes you just got a you got a sit
in there but also it's good to be down
sometimes to like to be in there and be
okay with that some shits got a change
hey what's up tuna on the long claw [ __ ]
this morning yeah it's pretty dope I
like that so like a lot of people will
be either in denial or they're resisting
so there's one way to change your
perspective and you're like no actually
I can see this and be grateful and I'm
happy right that's one way to look at it
but there's also another destructive way
where you say that to deny and reject
because you don't ever want to be sad so
then instead of like living that feeling
some people be like no I'm never sad
because life is always perfect yeah well
then that action that's what that's also
destructive to versus someone that's
like finding the positive but they're
accepting the reality that's the hardest
thing to do
yeah somebody that's always happening I
don't trust its president they're not
rich like if I know you are if I know
we're in the same boat like finances
like you are you're coming to me yeah
everything's great I'm like today nope
okay man that's just great as like okay
than your killer as simple as that like
you're nothing and all the spectrum of a
normal man because everything is not
great like that traffic that you spoke
up I [ __ ] hate rap yeah so let me
tell you the laundry list of things yes
long in my life it's like what y'all so
every time I'm saying like there has to
be there's a human connection that we
all vibe off of and like sometimes you
might be higher on a spectral sometimes
lower but you have to you have those air
band flows but if you're always here
it makes me think like right like that's
not healthy because the moment that you
finally do let it are it makes his way
out you could explode on anyone for the
wrong reason and that's not even if it
is like I rather be up here in denial
then out here good yeah he's behind you
all the way Kanye that's the way to go
how do you think what output a cog you
recently it don't matter what happens
and what happens in here is what matters
you sure well cuz he was a Tin Man and
the Tin Man didn't have a brain or heart
so
[Music]